bentornati
e mica troppo questo per youtube è
troppo questo no perché io quest'anno
voglio dare il 110 per cento per il mio
canale perché perché non si sa mai
non si sa mai perché youtube ha cambiato
per esempio l'algoritmo un'altra volta e
tutti i miei video potrebbero
all'improvviso sparire nel nulla e
quindi ho voluto fare questo ho voluto
regalarmi e regalarvi questa cosa qui
questo splendore
perché non si sa mai non si sa mai
perché potrei morire da un momento
all'altro e lasciare niente sul canale
perché potrebbe arrivare un fan e farmi
la john lennon ata nel senso che arriva
to say that ob se facciamo una foto
benvenuti in adrian
ebbene si oggi siamo qui per parlare di
una delle più grandi catastrofi della
televisione italiana negli ultimi dieci
anni
lunedì 21 gennaio 2019 è andata in onda
la prima puntata di adrian la serie
evento
so che molti di voi l'hanno vista ma
moltissimi altri hanno soltanto visto
quello che i loro amici hanno condiviso
su facebook
sappiate che quella è soltanto la punta
dell'iceberg tratto dell'iceberg che ha
fatto affondare il titanic
immaginatevi al posto del titanic
mediaset e al posto del capitano smith
pier silvio berlusconi adesso avete un
più o meno un immagine di quello che è
successo
insieme a voi voglio analizzare e
sviscerare tutte le informazioni che
abbiamo su questa serie è il capire
perché sia passata da serie evento ha
cancellato dai palinsesti
io sono qui ho tutte le informazioni in
mano e facciamo quasi una puntata di blu
notte
questo è adrian un mistero italiano
[Musica]
vorrei iniziare facendo un appello alla
televisione italiana
basta basta rovinarci grandi miti della
nostra infanzia io perche devo vedermi
claudio baglioni un artista che portavo
così quando ero piccolo sul palmo della
mano
un'icona della musica leggera italiana
da bar e a sanremo nel 2019
perché mi devo sorbire degli sketch che
anche negli anni 50 sarebbero risultati
antiquati e così anche adriano celentano
noi peter pan della via gluck baglioni a
sanremo che da bae celentano che fa una
serie animata su canale 5 manca soltanto
il canale di gameplay di de andrè dove
tra l'altro fa soltanto reaction ai
balli di fort knight e il cazzo di
filmino porno di lucio battisti che
invece di mandare il filmino una ragazza
in direct l'ha messo sulle storie per
sbaglio
l'immagine bellissimo quindi vi prego
basta con questo massacro mediatico
detto questo possiamo iniziare
le polemiche sulla serie partono già dal
trailer celentano lo spot di adrian
infastidisce gli spettatori volume
troppo molesto che se lo vieni a
chiedere a me l'hanno deciso i vertici
mediaset perché hanno visto in anteprima
l'episodio hanno notato che fosse una
merda e quindi ha detto sai cosa
facciamo è troppo tardi per tirarci
indietro
cerchiamo di ammazzare tutti con un
infarto no tipo moderno deathnote poi
arrivano le prime indiscrezioni che
dallo studio durante le prove
michelle hunziker e teo teocoli se la
tela noe leggendo queste notizie io
stavo già annusando il profumo del
capolavoro ovviamente però non ero
ancora convinto nello spendere un'intera
sera a guardare questa cosa qui finché
sulla pagina facebook ufficiale di
celentano non è apparso un promo vi
giuro su dio non ho mai visto uno spot
più incredibile di questo adriano in
bagno che si filma da solo mentre appare
la sua versione animata davanti alla
telecamere davanti allo specchio senza
una vera e propria prospettiva io ero in
estasi mistica tanto che ho voluto
contribuire al successo del progetto
poco prima dell'uscita però arrivano i
numeri dieci anni di produzione e tra i
20 ei 30 milioni di euro di costi
ora le notizie su questi dati sono molto
molto molto confuse a quanto pare ci
sono stati casini nella produzione che
l'hanno fatta saltare più volte dal 2009
insomma sono le caratteristiche per la
prima serata su canale 5 e mediaset ha
un disperato bisogno di ascolti
soprattutto dopo il flop
dell'attesissimo ritorno della
dottoressa giorno doccia gelata per
barbara d'urso ed è per questo motivo
prego che mi sono fatto stampare il
cartonato dello share di adrian un po
con tipo tipo memento mori
ma tralasciando tutte queste
informazioni le puntate in sé come sono
grazie per avermelo chiesto cercherò di
raccontarmi e di capire i motivi per i
quali questa serie sia un caso mediatico
nazionale cercando di dividere tutto
nelle quattro puntate non credo che
andrò a fondo nelle puntate
1 perché mediaset che mi fa un
così ma soprattutto perché le puntate
ufficialmente non ci sono da nessuna
parte né su mediaset play nei suoi
infiniti e fate conto che sui figli dice
la dottoressa giò però se voleste
recuperarli almeno il primo episodio
qualcuno l'ha caricato su hicks videos
adrian the italian and buy
ma state attenti perché non ci sono
scene di sesso esplicito come ricorda
giustamente nei commenti del video
arturia pendragon hentai non ho visto un
cazzo in tutti i sensi
francamente non mi sembra intaj se non
si vede ma anche un rapporto sessuale
almeno si è visto le zinne grazie
arturia
ogni puntata è divisa in due parti il
pre show ambientato in un teatro dove ci
sono sketch e monologhi fatti da comici
davanti ad un pubblico live e poi la
serie animata vera e propria il pre show
della prima puntata getta le basi per
tutte le altre lento noioso e veramente
veramente credermi veramente tanto
banale insieme a nino frassica si parla
di immigrati cercando di ironizzare con
uno sketch con l'arca di noè ma è
talmente atroce nelle battute nelle
tempistiche che tutto muore nei primi
due cazzo di minuti poi arriva il
monologo di natalino balasso noi
sappiamo le potenzialità che a natalino
balasso e qual è il suo e quanto è bravo
a fare il comico ma niente non basta
neanche quello una merda su tutti i
livelli satira vecchia su argomenti
stanchi passano soltanto dieci minuti e
su internet si scatena il finimondo una
serie di commenti così negativa che mi
ha ricordato un altro evento importante
della televisione italiana
quando ciccio è stato invitato a a mai
dire talk per chi non se lo ricordasse
questa è un'immagine catturata in quel
momento è così esumate un attimo potete
vedere ciccio vessato dalla gialappa's e
finalmente dopo un pochino arriva anche
celentano acclamato dal pubblico
solo che dice soltanto di numero 15
parole e va via
e parte la serie animata e io io mi sono
messo nei panni di quei poveracci che
sono stati invitati a teatro magari
dicendogli osta per dopo sette anni sta
per ritornare adriano in tv
vuoi far parte del pubblico dice cazzo
sì il mio artista preferito
e poi rimane seduto a guardare 52 minuti
di una serie animata proiettata contro
un muro a teatro e dopo dieci minuti di
agonia live finalmente inizia il motivo
per cui noi siamo qua e posso dirvi dal
profondo del cuore che le aspettative
sono state rispettate
la prima cosa che salta all'occhio sono
i disegni e le animazioni molti sul web
l'hanno definita una merda
animata malissimo disegnata ancora
peggio ma secondo me non è del tutto
vero
la verità è che in 52 minuti di episodio
si passa dall'avere dei disegni
effettivamente dettagliati a delle bozze
mai finite di vignette inesistente idem
le animazioni fluide e complesse anche
in scene con numerosi personaggi su
schermo fino ad arrivare a delle
fotografie animate con il fluidificante
photoshop
a volte assomigliano spaventosamente
alle animazioni dell'orso malosso a
monte assomigliano a quelle animazioni
dei videogiochi porno che c'erano i
primi anni del 2000 in flash quelle dove
dovevi cliccare un tasto solo per far
contrastare l'idea 22 personaggi per
fargli fare sesso virtualmente io esatto
ci giocavo un sacco solo in un secondo
momento arriva in faccia al pubblico la
trama molto confuso e molto molto noiosa
riassumo brevemente ambientata nel
futuristico 2068 adrian è un orologiaio
durante un concerto decide di prendere
il posto del cantante e fare un pezzo
sua diventa involontariamente famoso ma
proprio per questo parte una caccia
all'uomo per mano del governo e tra
l'altro il cantante di cui prende il
posto sul palco che assomiglia vagamente
ad un nemico di kenshiro e in realtà
giuliano dei negramaro davvero sta
cantando mentre tutto scorre sul palco e
adrian poi gli prende il posto
non so voi ma io sono veramente contento
che nel 2000 e 68 gli unici due cantanti
italiani sopravvissuti siano adriano
celentano e i negramaro sono niente ma
che peccato niente trap strano da questo
pilot però sono uscite due chicche
interessanti il viso di adriano a letto
con claudia mori che sembra uno di
quegli esperimenti dove un artista sotto
20 droghe diverse disegna 20 volte il
suo volto no qui siamo verso i 10 mg di
lory tab che dovrebbe essere derivanti
della codeina più o meno e poi l'ormai
famosissima per i mini che sono stati
creati casa con la palma che tra l'altro
non so se lo sapete ma questo non è un
disegno di milo manara come tutti gli
altri concept della serie ma questo è un
disegno proprio fatto da adriano
celentano e postato nel suo blog nel
2015 adriano
aggiornamento con scritto albero non
essere così rigoglioso se non comune ti
strangola poesia e io ho voluto
mangiarti adriano facendo costruire
tutto quanto è mannaggia
e poi ovviamente non potevano mancare
ulteriori polemiche durante un pezzo di
puntata ambientato a napoli appare un
edificio chiamato mafia international
capitanato da da un uomo cattivissimo
che si chiama grange style che una
curiosissima fusione non sto scherzando
è una crisi ma fusione tra frankenstein
e andrangheta ecco cosa mai potrebbe
andare storto con la comunità italiana
facendo questo tipo di rappreseglia
sociazione noi consumatori presenterà
querela contro la trasmissione di canale
5 per la rappresentazione di napoli
quale capitale di mafia international
horse e che dopo tutto questo casino
gli ascolti della puntata sono
incredibilmente medi per essere il
ritorno di celentano dopo sette anni di
inattività in televisione ma c'è una
particolarità nel segmento iniziale del
pre show quando appare lui siamo sui 5
milioni 997mila che circa il 22 per
cento di share
come dicevo medio per mediaset ma quando
inizia la serie animata si scende al
19,0 7 per cento a 4 milioni 544 mila
spettatori
praticamente perde un milione di
spettatori questo mi fa capire la
discrepanza di chi volesse vedere lui e
di chi fosse effettivamente interessato
al progetto animato
nella parte line del secondo episodio
invitano giovanni storti che fa uno
sketch con natalino balasso sempre sugli
stessi argomenti attuali ma troppo
ridondanti migranti reddito di
cittadinanza quota 100 e così via
adrian ha questo potere di rendere le
persone potenzialmente divertenti in day
cazzo di clown senza talento la serie
animata invece sembra prendere la strada
della noia è nella mia testa pensavo
perfetto per me finisce qui se diventa
solo per curare le animazioni disegni
non ne vale la pena
ma a un certo punto il twist si scopre
che adrian di giorno aggiusta orologi di
notte è un supereroe mascherato chiamato
la volpe che se ne va in giro con questa
maschera nera che assomiglia un po
azzurro se devo dire più che un
supereroe e tra l'altro giorno in
spagnolo vuol dire proprio volpe quindi
e zorro quindi e zorro con tutti cazzo
di supereroi da cui potevano prendere
spunto hanno preso spunto dalle più
noioso mai creato sulla faccia della
terra che non è manco italiano avessero
preso spunto dai vecchi e dimenticati
super eroi italiani che podlech fulmine
supereroi italo americano del 1938
protagonista di avventure incredibili
tra le quali la bottega del cinese il
mistero del colon è l'indimenticabile
rivolta [ __ ] e invece no zorro ma non è
questo il vero colpo di scena la volpe
vede due ragazze che stanno per essere
violentata in una scena anche abbastanza
forte e le salva avrebbe potuto stare
zitto salutare e andare via
invece si gira le guarda negli occhi
ancora scosse dal trauma e dice se
avesse bevuto qualche bicchierino in
meno forse avreste evitato l'increscioso
approccio con quei tipi loschi panico su
internet esplode il cataclisma
ma mentre tutti gridavano giustamente
allo scandalo io stavo applaudendo dalla
gioia perché in una maniera un po
perversa era esattamente questo che
volevo
dudley con la serie non il classico
trash da lavoro fatto male ma proprio
essere fuori luogo
ed è da quel momento che ho iniziato a
prendere appunti lo share di questo
secondo episodio ricordandoci sempre che
il pre show fa sempre circa un
milioncino un milioncino e qualcosa in
più se chiude al 13,20 6 per cento
2.887.000 spettatori la meta quasi di
quello della puntata precedente che non
è andata in onda una settimana prima ma
il giorno prima in un giorno ha perso la
metà degli spettatori che per un
progetto costato tra i 20 ei 30 milioni
è durato dieci anni
non credo sia accettato dai vertici
mediaset sopra si trema e piersilvio
suda sapendo il putiferio che ha causato
lo scorso episodio come affronteranno il
problema con una delle più grandi
paraculate che io abbia mai visto in
vita mia
chiamano un'attrice ilenia pastorelli
che tra l'altro è anche molto brava e
l'attrice che ha fatto ve la ricorderete
probabilmente per lo chiamavano jeeg
robot e le fanno fare monologo sulla
violenza contro le donne
collegata alla frase se l'è cercata a
[ __ ] vogliono cercare di farci
sentire in colpa per un problema che
hanno creato loro sarebbe come urlare
viva gli animali con un pezzo di
cheeseburger che ti cade dalla bocca e
stato un disastro ma ma la parte animata
ha riservato una piccola gemma questo ed
arianna e il travestimento che usa
adrian nella serie per farsi catturare
d'aria adrian ha invertito le due
lettere e ha messo il naso una parrucca
gli occhiali la gobba
non lo so io volevo di fulmine contro il
pugilatore mascherato e invece no mi
devo sorbire la befana andreotti ormai a
quel punto lì o fiutato la cancellazione
e ho perso un po le speranze lo share è
sceso al 10,55 per cento con 2 milioni a
malapena gli spettatori e mancano ancora
sette puntate
nella quarta puntata arriva al dramma
celentano non si presenta nel preshow
tonfo adrian ascolti polverizzati
celentano sparisce piersilvio ormai me
lo immagino come il sottotenente di last
action hero col fumo dalle orecchie al
posto di adriano però appare rientrare
nell'arca perché miliardi e tutto mio
non so esattamente il perché
probabilmente perché gigi sabani è morto
anni fa e non è più disponibile poco
prima della puntata animata arriva pure
l'esibizione di un ballerino ucraino che
ha la faccia di putin tatuata immenso i
pettorali cioè come sia una puntata di
domenica in andasse ospite primo levi
con una svastica tatuata sul petto tipo
american history hicks la parte animata
invece è in fase molto calante poca
carne al fuoco ma un sacco di pipponi a
due mani a celentano che si presenta
come colui che aprì gli occhi alla gente
salva le menti di noi poveri ignoranti
ma almeno abbiamo una soluzione ad un
enigma che va avanti da tre settimane
qual è lo studio che ha fatto le
animazioni di adrian sono riuscito a
trovare un vecchio articolo del 2005 del
sito fanclub di adriano celentano in cui
c'è scritto che lo studio legato alle
animazioni e lo studio sempre lo studio
sec è uno studio nord coreano che tra le
tante cose a cui elaborato ci sono
quelle sottomarche della disney tipo
simba junior nella nazionale di calcio o
cose simili ma soprattutto è l'autore
delle animazioni di due film di
creazione italiana sulla leggenda del
titanic chiamati appunto la leggenda del
titanic e tenta colino che si sia
scoperto questa cosa qua è incredibile
ma non solo passino le animazioni ok
come mai i disegni di milo manara a
tratti siano così orrendi abbiamo la
risposta anche di questo perché come
ogni mistero italiano che si rispetti
c'è sempre un colpo di scena
questo e voi credevate fosse soltanto
una cartellina per tenere i fogli in
realtà è una lettera
una lettera di milo manara che dopo aver
visto i suoi disegni devastati
in questa serie ha giustamente preso le
distanze come sanno tutti quelli che si
occupano di cinema di animazione questi
disegni sarebbero dovuti essere
utilizzati come riferimento per la
realizzazione delle animazioni vere e
proprie purtroppo la decisione di
utilizzarli non è stata mia
e a suo tempo non ho potuto che far
presente la mia forza e perplessità in
merito
praticamente questi hanno preso le bozze
che milo manara fatto soltanto per dare
un'idea del senso che avrebbe dovuto
avere la serie e questo e quello studio
secche le animate e questo spiega il
perché di quei piccoli incubi ma anche
sapendo questa cosa qua non basta a
risollevare la serie che cala al 7,66
per cento con un milione e mezzo di
spettatori in quattro puntate adrian
scomparso dai palinsesti che fine farà
lo show di celentano ufficialmente lo
rinviano di una settimana per un malanno
di stagione di adriano guarda caso per
la prossima settimana lo spostano al
martedì perché lunedì ci sarebbe stato
montalbano e si stavano pagando per la
competizione o il martedì sarebbe poi
iniziata la champions quindi decidono
ragazzi loro inviamo di una settimana
poi quella settimana diventano due
e poi sparisce dai palinsesti cazzo
lunghetto sto malanno di stagione
e qui finisce la tragica storia di un
mistero italiano di una serie che
sarebbe potuta diventare l'avanguardia
italiana e invece alla fine giace al
fondo di una rupe
esattamente come nell'episodio la rupe
del silenzio di di fulmine e allora
questa parte qua non ho neanche il
copione perché voglio che sia il più
sincera possibile
adriano uno scemo su internet cerca di
spiegarsi il perché perché io io ero
contento quando è uscita la serie non
tanto perché fosse stata se sarebbe
stato un disastro annunciato e quindi
avrei riso da solo a casa mia non solo
per quello ma perché è incredibile è
stata una voce incredibile nella
televisione tale va su canale 5 una cosa
del genere fatta da un cantante dopo
tanti tanti anni di carriera e credibile
anche perché tu combattevi con programmi
tipo gees my age sto cazzo di programma
con enrico papi che un programma
semplicemente dove de la gente deve
indovinare che età a una persona
soltanto visiva ma che idea del cazzo è
sarebbe come fare un programma in prima
serata su raiuno che chi tocca per
ultimo lo attraversava in porta no non è
un programma non è un coso programma
quindi ero contento adriano
ero contento veramente secondo me questa
cosa qua non ha funzionato perché non si
è capito per chi cazzo fosse stasera
perché i giovani erano interessati alla
serie animata ma gente tipo i miei
genitori o la gente di 50 60 anni che ti
adora da tanto tempo da te ne frega un
cazzo della serie animata adriano niente
ne frega
e infatti riguardavano soltanto il pre
show mentre chi guardava la serie
animata arriva da in questo decennio in
cui tu hai fatto
hai lavorato alla serie c'è stato di
tutto netflix non netflix pirateria
internet e l'internet si è voluto
tantissimo questi dieci anni
la tua è una serie che è nata vecchia ma
vecchia veramente perché la cosa
peggiore di questa serie qui non è tanto
le animazioni non è tanto i disegni
non è tanto che fosse trash non è tanto
che fosse noiosa la parte iniziale noi
tanto che fossero banali monologhi e le
battute e che insulta all'intelligence
dello spettatore lo spettatore medio che
usa internet come me come tutti che
usiamo internet da anni perché quello
che alcune persone su twitter e su
facebook hanno scritto se vuoi
ascoltaste un po di più la sera invece
di criticare capireste quanti chiavi di
lettura ci sono ma le chiavi di lettura
di adria sono di una balena banalità
sconcertante adriano ti dico una cosa
non cambiarla in autunno questa serie
qua metterà su internet
i vigili etiopi gli autori vieni da noi
vieni da noi su internet che alla gente
su internet azioni perché dopo una
settimana c'è la settimana dove la gente
poi se ne sbatte i [ __ ] di quello
che puoi fare una merda puoi fare uno
show che non funziona
una serie che non funziona le challenge
cross marcia le puoi fare quello che
vuoi poi la gente si incazza
ma puglie ne frega i [ __ ] non ci
sono vertici mediaset che ti fanno
cagare in mano non c'è bisogno di
mostrare un certificato medico per dire
ragazzi purtroppo non ci sono
vieni su internet se uno ti vendo il mio
spazio
il mio spazio su youtube il mio canale
così posso mettere un po più divido
facciamo magari il martedì mettiamo
adria che lunedi c'e montalbano quindi
non si sa mai e vieni fallo da me tanto
chi cazzo me ne frega un cazzo alla
gente e quinta dopo tutto questo ti dico
grazie per aver creato questa serie qui
potevamo farne a meno però almeno ci hai
provato
abbiamo dato un occhio a quello che
sarebbe potuto essere il futuro
grazie